كنا نذهب بشكل أساسي إلى مكان
وقوع تلك الضربة الصاروخية
الليلة الماضية على ذلك المبنى السكني
الذي قتل فيه العديد من الأشخاص لأنه
بالطبع لا تزال هناك عملية إنقاذ كبيرة جارية
هناك وقد
وصلنا للتو إلى مكان الحادث وتركت سياراتنا
عندما  أصيب المنزل الذي
كانت مركبتنا أمامه بضربة صاروخية ،
كان انفجارًا شديدًا
قريبًا جدًا ، أود أن أقول ربما 40 أو 50
ياردة من موقعنا ، لذلك ذهبنا
نحاول الذهاب إلى ملجأ في محاولة للدخول
إلى مأوى  وأثناء
قيامنا بذلك ، استدرت ، وكان بإمكانك
رؤية الصاروخ الثاني يصيب
نفس المنطقة بالضبط ونحن نعلم بالفعل أن هناك
أشخاصًا أصيبوا بجروح خطيرة على
الأرض هناك ، ومن غير الواضح ما إذا
كان عدد القتلى وعددهم بالطبع صحيح
الآن هناك عملية إنقاذ كبيرة
جارية هناك ، لكنني أعتقد أنه من المهم
لمشاهدينا أن يفهموا أن هذه المنطقة
التي كانت موجودة فيها كانت هناك
عملية بحث وإنقاذ نشطة في
منطقة سكنية واليوم
استهدف الروس نفس المنطقة تمامًا
بفردين  صواريخ ثقيلة وكان هذا حيث
كان هناك الكثير من المدنيين هناك في
الشارع لم نر أي شخص في
طريق الجيش في الشوارع أو
أي نوع من المنشآت العسكرية
كان ذلك في قلب مدينة
محرقة الجثث و  بالطبع
قررنا مغادرة تلك المنطقة بأسرع ما
يمكن بعد أن أدركنا أن الساحل قد تم
تطهيره